Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to cover many important
questions in life.
For instance, who is this?
This is Halle Berry.
Now, I show you this, who is it?
It is, of course, also Halle Berry.
And if I show you this piece of text, who
does it refer to?
Again, Halle Berry.
So why are these questions interesting?
Well, an earlier paper found out from brain
readings that we indeed have person neurons
in our brain.
These are neurons specialized to recognize
a particular human being.
That is quite interesting.
And what is even more interesting is that
not that we have person neurons, but that
these neurons are multimodal.
What does that mean?
This means that we understand the essence
of what makes Halle Berry, regardless of whether
it is a photo, a drawing, or anything else.
I see, alright.
Well then, our first question today is, do
neural networks also have multimodal neurons?
Not necessarily.
The human brain is an inspiration for an artificial
neural network that we can simulate on our
computers, but do they work like the brain?
Well, if we study their inner workings, our
likely answer will be no, not in the slightest.
But still, no one can stop us from a little
experimentation, so let’s try this for a
common neural network architecture.
This neuron responds to human faces and says
that this is indeed a human face.
So far so good.
Now, if we provide it with a drawing of a
human face, it won’t recognize it to be
a face.
Well, so much for this multimodal idea, this
one is surely not a brain in a jar.
But wait, we don’t give up so easily around
here.
This is not the only neural network architecture
that exists, let’s grab a different one.
This one is called OpenAI’s CLIP, and it
is remarkably good at generalizing concepts.
Let’s see how it can deal with the same
problem.
Yes, this neuron responds to spiders, and
Spiderman.
That’s the easy part.
Now, please hold on to your papers, because
now comes the hard part.
Drawings and comics of spiders and Spiderman.
Yes, it responds to that too!
Wonderful.
Now comes the final boss, which is spider-related
writings.
And.. it responds to that too.
Now, of course, this doesn’t mean that this
neural network would be a brain in a jar,
but it is a tiny bit closer to our thinking
than previous architectures.
And now comes the best part, this insight
opens up the possibility for three amazing
experiments.
Experiment number one.
Essence.
So it appears to understand the essence of
a concept or a person.
That is absolutely amazing, so I wonder if
we can turn this problem around and ask what
it thinks about different concepts?
It would be the equivalent to saying give
me all things spiders and Spiderman.
Let’s do that with Lady Gaga.
It says this is the essence of Lady Gaga.
We get the smug smile, very good.
And it says that the essence of Jesus Christ
is this, and it also includes the crown of
thorns.
So far, flying colors.
Now, we will see some images of feelings,
some of you might find some of them disturbing.
I think the vast majority of you humans will
be just fine looking at them, but I wanted
to let you know just in case.
So, what is the essence of someone being shocked?
Well, this.
I can attest to that, this is basically me
when reading this paper.
My eyes were popping out just like this.
Sleepiness.
Yes, that is a coffee person before coffee
alright.
The happiness, crying and seriousness neurons
also embody these feelings really well.
Experiment number two, adversarial attacks.
We know that OpenAI’s clip responds to photos
and drawings of the same thing, so let’s
try some nasty attacks involving combining
the two.
When we give it these images, it can classify
them with ease.
This is an Apple, this is a laptop, a mug,
and so on.
Nothing too crazy going on here.
However, now, let’s prepare a nasty adversarial
attack.
Previously, sophisticated techniques were
developed to fool a neural network by adding
some nearly imperceptible noise to an image.
Let’s have a look at how this works.
First, we present a previous neural network
with an image of a bus, and it will successfully
tell us that yes, this is indeed a bus.
Of course it does.
Now, we show it not an image of a bus, but
a bus plus some carefully crafted noise that
is barely perceptible, that forces the neural
network to misclassify it as an ostrich.
I will stress that this is not any kind of
noise, but the kind of noise that exploits
biases in the neural network, which is, by
no means trivial to craft.
So now, I hope you are expecting a sophisticated
adversarial attack against the wonderful CLIP
neural network.
Yes, that will do.
Or will it?
Let’s see together!
Yes, indeed, I don’t know if you knew, but
this is not an apple, this is a pizza.
And so is this one.
The neural network fell for these ones, but
it was able to resist this sophisticated attack
in the case of the coffee mug and the phone.
Perhaps the pizza labels had too small a footprint
in an image, so let’s try an even more sophisticated
version of this attack.
Now, you may think that this is a chihuahua,
but that is completely wrong, because this,
is a pizza indeed.
Not a chihuahua in sight anywhere in this
image.
No-no!
So what did we learn here?
Well, interestingly, this CLIP neural network
is more general than previous techniques,
however, its superpowers come at a price.
And that price is that it can be exploited
easily with simple systematic attacks.
That is a great lesson indeed.
Experiment number three, understanding feelings.
Now this will be one heck of an experiment.
We will try to answer the age-old question,
which is, how would you describe feelings
to a machine?
Well, it’s hard to explain such a concept,
but all humans understand what being bored
means.
However, luckily, these neural networks have
neurons, and they can use those to explain
to us what they think about different concepts.
An interesting idea here is that feelings
could sort of emerge as a combination of other,
more elementary neurons that are already understood.
If this sounds a little nebulous, let’s
go with that example, what does the machine
think it means that someone is bored?
Well, it says that bored, is relaxed + grumpy.
This isn’t quite the way I think about it,
but not bad at all, little machine.
I like the way you think.
Let’s try one more.
How do we explain to a machine what a surprise
means?
Well, it says surprise is celebration + shock.
Nice.
What about madness?
Let’s see.
Evil + serious + a hint of mental illness.
And when talking about combinations, there
are two more examples that I really liked.
If we are looking for text that embodies evil,
we get something like this.
And now, give me an evil building.
Oh yes, I think that works really well, but
there are internet forums where we have black-belt
experts specializing in this very topic, so,
if you are one of them, please let me know
in the comments what you think.
The paper also contains a ton more information,
for instance, there is an experiment with
the Stroop effect.
This explores whether the neural network reacts
to the meaning of the text, or the color of
the text?
I will only tease this because I would really
like you to read the paper, which is available
below in the video description.
So there we go, neural networks are by no
means brains in a jar, they are very much
computer programs, however, CLIP has some
similarities, and we also found that there
is a cost to that.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!